[Music]
this is a very simple straightforward
Act the president broke the law I
believe it was inappropriate I do not
believe it was impeachable what happened
was without question in my mind as
someone who sat in those rooms and
listened to these witnesses as the
American people will soon have an
opportunity to do was extortion we don't
get to have anybody from our side out
there to tell our side of the story so
this is going to be excuse me more of
the same as last week we don't expect
anything different
well Wednesday it all starts in front of
you the viewers public hearings up on
Capitol Hill
Wednesday morning meantime the GOP would
like to have their own witnesses come up
and testify they include a long list
including the whistleblower hunter Biden
Devin Archer former board member of
burry smih Nellie or Kurt Volker Tim
Morrison a former NSC senior director
David Hale and Alexandre chalupa former
DNC staffer who worked with the
Ukrainian embassy to try to get
political dirt on the 2016 Trump
campaign but they likely won't get any
of those let's bring in our panel bill
McGurn main street columnist for The
Wall Street Journal Barry Weiss staff
editor and writer for The New York Times
opinion and an author of the new book
how to fight anti-semitism and Bill
Hemmer co-anchor of America's newsroom
here on Fox okay bill we expect you know
some interesting things come with yeah
my guess is these witnesses will be
credible I think they'll have good
resumes I think they'll make a very good
impression I think for the complete
story you're going to have to watch
carefully for the cross-examination I
spoke with the House Republican leak
today very close to the process and he
described the situation the following
way Adam Schiff is a former prosecutor
from LA he will develop a quote story
line in his opening statement it will
make claims of abuse of power and claims
of obstruction of justice when the
cross-examination takes place
he described fire five areas where
Republicans will Center on number one a
lot of the information they believe from
bill Taylor the first witness on
Wednesday one every second third and
sometimes
and information they will emphasize was
the President's request consistent with
US law regarding corruption laws
overseas as it relates to Ukraine number
three the verismo hunter Biden
connection was it illegal if not should
it be number four the u.s. president can
recall an ambassador to any time it's
his call ultimately remember the
Ambassador testifies on Friday and the
fifth point he made it was the Trump
administration support of Ukraine was
much greater than what you saw under the
Obama administration meaning we gave
Ukraine more equipment to defend itself
against Russia and Vladimir Putin it's
really interesting
obviously the opening statement last
time for Adam Schiff provided the
president a lot of ammunition to say
that he made up all of these things
which he did on the opening statement in
the hearings when it all started but
Barry this is the Democrats chance to
put their foot forward to affect public
opinion right and I mean to me with
what's fascinating is that the
Republican argument has sort of moved
significantly the longer this has gone
on it started off as read the transcript
you just got to read the transcript it's
gonna be clear you know that the
president is in the right well everyone
read the transcript and then the
argument became it's not actually
impeachable it's just an appalling thing
it's a gross thing that the president
did but it's not in P chable I think now
starting Wednesday we're gonna have an
opportunity to hear from all of these
credible people and the question is you
know if John Bolton is calling this
thing a drug deal John Bolton also part
of the deep state I mean the number of
people that were here John Baldwin
before all of this goes full I'm aware
it was interesting but I'm saying the
number of people who are required for
the Republicans to make to make the case
that sort of Trump is in the right and
all of these people are somehow in the
deep state colluding against him it just
doesn't pass the sniff test to me yeah
well the president still is bill
tweeting where is the whistleblower who
gave so much false information must
testify along with Schiff and others to
think I signed the whistleblower
protection act and then read the
transcript it is perfect he's hoping
that the transcript still stands on its
own even though as Berry mentions there
has been some evolution especially from
some geo
members yeah I think look first to put
this in context we know what the outcome
of this drama is they're going through
the hearings to get to impeach me I
don't think there is any doubt once mrs.
Pelosi move forward that there's going
to be an impeachment the question is I
think there's a lot of good concerns
about where the whistleblower came from
and so forth and you know in the same
way that a lot of people were angry when
bill Barr said I'm gonna look into the
beginning of the FBI investigation how
and when it started a lot of those
saying people don't want us to look at a
whistleblower now I think this is all
drama I think it doesn't matter I think
what matters and is in the Senate I
don't even think the president's
complaints about due process I don't
think there's a lot of legal rights I
think the Democrats can do what they
want but at the end of the day you're
playing to the American public and you
have to persuade them that this is fair
and principled and going forward I don't
I don't think that's going to be the
case you know Lindsey Graham I think
when you put that resolution condemning
the house that's going to have an effect
I mean just trying to let me just return
to real quick to the former UN
Ambassador to the u.s. nikki Haley who
brings up what she essentially paints as
a conspiracy inside the administration
with two cabinet members take a listen
instead of saying that to me they should
have been saying that to the president
not asking me to join them on their
sidebar plan it should have been go tell
the president what your differences are
and quit if you don't like what he's
doing but to undermine a president is
really a very dangerous thing and it
goes against the Constitution and it
goes against what the American people
want and it was was offensive was
talking in there about former Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson and former White
House chief of staff John Kelly Kelly
responded to CBS saying if I resistance
and stalling she means putting a staff
process in place to ensure the president
knew all the pros and cons of what
policy decision he might be
contemplating so he could make an
informed decision then guilty as charged
I guess the question I have del is if
ambassador Haley knew that there was
this effort to undermine the president
why didn't she tell me that's a good
question listening or hurt today though
I think she's exactly
right but I mean they don't over the
book maybe you know she put it down a
written word so I believe the word she's
saying or at least the correct but she's
right when she says tell him not me
you work for him you don't work for me
I'm not suggesting Nikki Haley's working
for some angle this administration I
think she has that certain turns been
critical the president I don't think
she's sucking up right now but I think
she's right about that point if you got
a problem with the commander-in-chief
the men who employs you go to him and
not me Barry I think she's trying to
maintain optionality to run in 2024 and
I think she's doing it in a brilliant
way she can make the argument that she's
never been an effort Trumper she's been
a sort of seldom Trumper sometimes
Trumper
she's criticized the president about
Syria she's criticized the president
when he smeared Elijah coming she spoke
out I think it was you know it should
have been
it was wonderful when she spoke out in
defense of the protesters for democracy
and Hong Kong so she's maintained a
critical distance on sort of given
number of things that she can she's
thread this needle I think in a way
that's been pretty elegant people that
love Trump seem to like her but then I
know lots of people who are never Trump
who are also really really warm to nikki
Haley sure she's are the only exiting
official who got an oval office send-off
from the president final word on this
okay I think that's interesting to put
it this way because nikki Haley has
disagreed with the President on on
various issues hard issues Hongkong and
so forth Lindsey Graham has also done
that too but the moment they take a
principled stand saying the president
has a point here on the impeachment then
all of a sudden they're a sycophant
and they're unprincipled and they're
doing it just for their political I mean
maybe we ought to give him credit that
if they were willing to speak honestly
before this is what they believe
no longer have jobs really just one less
thing about the whistleblower you know
if an informant calls the NYPD and says
there's a house full of cocaine at the
end of the block and the NYPD NYPD goes
there and they find a house full of
cocaine and then we find out that the
informant was biased against that
homeowner does it actually matter if the
person was biased if the cocaine is
there sure
so by consolidating you know like I
guess that it just raises questions why
Adam Schiff at the beginning wanted to
hear from the whistleblower said he
should be called up and then when the
story comes out that he actually and his
staff met with him beforehand suddenly
he's not relevant at all but if there
are 10 people who are verifying what
this person I'm sure and we're gonna see
that play out and then last couple days
I gotta go because we have a second
panel